hello and welcome to the spectators
alternative conference if you've been
with us all day welcome back if this is
your first panel you're in for a
great one uh today we're going to be
discussing the government's new obesity
strategy or the revival of it
the title of this panel is the nanny
state crusade is the war on obesity at
the tip of the iceberg
the headline partner for today's panel
is the institute of economic affairs the
panel was
organized by the think tank it's been
wonderful to have some of britain's
leading think tanks
joining us for our alternative
conference i'm kate andrews economics
correspondent at the spectator and
delighted to chair this event and so i
thought i'd kick off
by uh taking a quote from a telegraph
column from 2004
which reads face it it's your own fault
you're fat
uh that was penned by now prime minister
boris johnson
um it's all your own fault you're fat uh
to be very specific there um at how far
we've come
we now have a rather libertarian prime
minister once upon a time
um reasserting the obesity strategy in
the wake of cove at 19 hoping to get
the public into better shape this could
include a ban on tv
and online average for high in fat
food high in fat and in sugar and salt
before 9 pm
um end of deals like buy one get one
free on unhealthy foods
i'm sure chris snowden will talk to us
about the definition of
unhealthy foods soon um but i'm going to
introduce our panel we have steve bryan
mp
member of parliament for winchester
christopher snowden head of lifestyle
economics at the iaea
dolly theas co-founder of 50 50
parliament and joanna williams
founder of cieo um huge thanks to all of
you for joining us we're going to rattle
through some opening remarks two to
three minutes each
so we can go straight to questions i'll
probably abuse my position as chair
to ask a few but we'd love to get
questions from the audience
you can submit them on spectator tv
they'll come straight to me and i'll put
them
to our panel uh steve bryan let's start
with you
thanks kate thanks very much for doing
this thanks for asking me
um thanks for spectating the ia for
organizing it
um just i mean obviously i just i was an
mp for winchester as you say i also
was probably health minister from from
2017 to to mid-2019
so i guess the context of this event and
i mean i'm not sure when this event was
was dreamt up with this title but the
context of it like everything has to
come in the context of coronavirus
and uh you know when i when i used to
sit in the tea room here in the house of
commons and get
some some questions or some raised
eyebrows even from some of my colleagues
about some of our so-called
nanny state initiatives nobody could
have dreamt that we would have a
government that was uh
imposing such restrictions on our
freedoms
uh that that makes my my version of the
lonely state look rather
tame i mean so obesity seems to be the
issue that has
sparked the ire if you like um of of
this event and
what prompted it so so why was i moved
in
in office to to do some of the things
that i
that i did and propose some of the
things that i proposed and subsequent
administrations
including those who've had as you say
with boris johnson or rather damascene
conversion
uh to this particular agenda this is
somebody who ran for the leadership of
my party describing
um the sugar tax as as sin taxes
so i mean look i would say this that
nobody
nobody wants to see people deprived of
the foods they love you know and we've
all obviously got a right to make our
own
decisions about what we eat what we
drink what we put into our body but the
fact remains
obesity is a huge problem in this
country particularly for children
one in three children are now overweight
or obese by the time they leave primary
school we've got some of the highest
levels of obesity
in europe and you know worryingly the
amount of
morbidly obese children is also on the
rise as is type 2 diabetes in
in kids so you know we're putting young
people at risk of developing
dangerous chronic conditions um that
could take years of their life and i
i always felt that and clearly so do
many of my colleagues
uh now that it would be rather
unforgivable
unforgivable not to act i mean just to
touch on on a diabetes point i mean the
nhs
spends about 10 billion pounds a year on
diabetes
that's that's just under 10 of its
entire budget
so about 90 percent of people with
diabetes have got i've got the type 2
and and we know that obesity is
responsible for the vast majority of
someone's risk of developing
type 2 so and we have some very high
profile examples of people who have
delayed
or or turned around their type 2
diabetes through
turning around their weight management
so i would suggest that on
on diabetes it's it's critically
important on cancer i mean i never knew
this until i was the public health
minister but i mean you know
being overweight and obese is the
biggest preventable cause
of cancer after smoking in the uk
so you know a child who is obese
is obviously more likely to be so as an
adult so if we act
early and change their behavior then we
prevent them from uh from a lifetime of
avoidable ill health
and disease and then just just finally
on
um on covet
encoded you know we know that obesity
has been widely uh
recognized as a as a leading risk factor
for people with severe illness or almost
about three quarters of people
in critical hair with kobit are living
with being overweight or obese
so i would suggest that events have have
borne out our desire to act
and whether the act that i
that i tried to do and some of the stuff
i propose and some of the stuff that
johnson government has taken on with the
launch of its obesity strategy
uh was it last month no it's the end of
july now um
i don't know and and that that's to be
debated i i don't think
on its own it will um there is much more
that needs to be done as far as what
next
uh to the title of your debate you know
i i don't see it as a set course i don't
necessarily see it as a prescription for
for more nanny state in every single
area but if you if you want three areas
where you could go next
um i would suggest smoking i would
suggest
alcohol so our old favorite cigarettes
and alcohol
plus the very early years agenda which
is something that andrea bledsoem
is working on here in parliament on
behalf of the prime minister and you
could well see
more nanny state if you want to call it
that um
but you know one man's uh one woman's
nanny state is another versus
interventionism
and uh and i would i would defend action
thanks steve uh over to joanna
thank you so i agree with steve that
if we compare where we are today to six
months ago
uh six months ago it would be absolutely
unthinkable
uh that the government would be
mandating ten o'clock closing time
for pubs mask wearing in shops
how many people we can meet with in
public in private
i'm struggling to work out whether we're
allowed to mingle
if we bump into our friends when we're
walking down the high street
uh it just seems like who we can have
sex with
uh whether students will be allowed home
for christmas or not
so the answer to the question is obesity
just the tip of the iceberg
i think it absolutely is because over
the past six months we've seen that when
it comes to protecting the nation's
health
there is absolutely no length uh the
government is not
prepared to go to it's prepared to
intervene in
all the all areas of our lives
now what i would like to argue is that
this intervention
call it intervention or call it nanny
statism
actually creates health problems it it
doesn't lead to any solution whatsoever
and i think it's really interesting
data that's just coming out today that
shows that areas that have been under
the most strict
local lockdowns not shown apart from one
area
there is no reduction um compared to the
rest of the country
in um cases of coronavirus
these lockdowns have been ineffective
because people are breaking
the rules essentially and i'm not saying
that to berate people i'm saying there's
something about human nature
when confronted by all these
restrictions and regulations
and to answer the question why i think
this i want to just
give a very very quick quote from my
favorite philosopher
emmanuel kent um he says that laziness
and cowardice are the reasons why such a
large part of mankind
gladly remains minors or their lives it
is so
comfortable to be a minor if i have a
book
that thinks for me a pastor who acts as
my conscience
a physician who prescribes my diet then
i have no need to think
man becomes incapable of using his own
understanding because he is never
permitted
to try it to throw off this immaturity
we need only freedom freedom to make
public use of our own reason
in all matters and i think this freedom
is what we're not being allowed
in matters of our own health right now
or
in relation to obesity um smoking and
alcohol consumption for a very very long
time
and i think it's only with this freedom
that we can actually as mature adults
reach decisions for ourselves
and i think this is so important because
as steve illustrates
when we hand responsibility over our
health over to
health professionals and government
ministers they have very different
concerns to us their concerns are driven
by life expectancy
keep up keeping people alive for as long
as possible
and money how much is this costing the
nhs
whereas when you actually talk to people
their concerns are far more to do with
quality
of life rather than quantity of life yes
people want to live for a long time but
people
people want to be able to see their
relatives people want to be able to see
their children
at christmas time it's not just about
staying alive to be locked
down in isolation on your own
at home all day never going out never
seeing another person
for many people that's simply not a life
worth living and i think the same is
actually true of food
as well food and nourishments not simply
about keeping us alive
sustaining us for me food is a real
source of pleasure
and it makes me happy to eat nice
fatty food whether it's healthy or not
thanks joanna over to dolly
thanks so much um i would also agree
i love delicious food um but i will get
on to that
um i want to start it's so interesting
that um people think that or associate
boris is a as a libertarian
um i would like to take this opportunity
to remind everyone
that he introduced a sugar levee in city
hall before the government did
so he has he's had multiple um
kind of guys when it comes to
intervention previously
and uh and going actually way beyond uh
prior to that
um but anyway i'm i am i'm gonna make
sort of some of the more
um uh
i'm being asked if i want my video but
it will start to pack up if i
if i use it i'm gonna and then i'm gonna
i'm gonna start on some of the kind of
more
um in-line points uh with what's been
said before and then
go on to something that i hope um will
be of interest to
uh today's audience um but broadly my
viewers if given the choice most people
would probably choose to be fit and well
rather than unfit and unwell
um so but it isn't always be easy to be
so
be so and we don't always do the stuff
that makes that happen whether that's
you know losing weight to all the
obvious stuff drinking a bit less giving
up smoking
being more physically active um we kind
of know what we need to do
to achieve these things but we don't
always do it even when the opportunity
is there so
you know if you if you can buy healthier
foods or if you technically can go for a
run why is it that we don't do it so
that leaves the questions of why don't
we do this especially
um especially if we aspire to be in i
don't know a better shape
of health or whatever it is and what can
be done to make it easier
and i'm basically fascinated by this and
uh
i'm fascinated enough to be uh spending
my kind of life at the moment
researching it
and ultimately what i want is for it
just to be easy
for everyone regardless of circumstance
and other things going on in our lives
uh to live a healthier life without
having really to think about it too much
and without it taking away meaningful
choice so
if that is enjoying fatty foods or
whatever i'm definitely not interested
in
banning that kind of stuff um but i just
i'm interested in a world where it makes
it very easy without us having to think
about it
essentially and we currently live in a
world where we are disproportionately
bombarded by the kind of unhealthier
options and don't always have a
healthier option
available to hand at the same time as
we're told we should be
losing weight and i thought my colleague
recently put it very well
she said irrespective of how much
education encouragement and motivation
we give people to eat better
it is very hard to make healthier
choices in a context
constantly sending the opposite message
whether that's the fact that you know
fewer than five percent of adverts are
for fruit and veg or
almost 60 of food adverts seen by kids
online or for junk food
is this sending a message that these
things are treats when they make over
half our tv adverts for example
so again um coming back to what joanna
was saying
um it is important to make the point
that healthier food doesn't mean
disgusting food
or boring food i love food and
would be very sad if i lived on a you
know carrot stick diet
and i certainly are not calling for that
either
um and actually it relates to a point of
reformulation that i've got views on
that aren't necessarily what people
might expect from
someone working in public health but you
know overly focusing on reformulated
food to the point where it's
disgusting is definitely not in my
interest um
but basically i love delicious food and
recently took a train that made me think
about
how hard it is to to sometimes find
healthy delicious
food um when i had a couple of stop-offs
and tried to find some food on root and
literally all i could find
were very sad looking beige sandwiches
and otherwise it was the obvious crystal
chocolate
and um i'd have to eat a lot of them to
feel full so
um i basically just want a world as i
said where it's easy to be fit and well
without having to think about it too
much and where of course we can enjoy
treats but where these so-called treats
aren't
much more easily available than the
delicious hopefully delicious
alternatives
um that are healthier um but the
question i wanted to come on to
for this event in particular and i'd be
really interested to hear if we have
enough time other people's thoughts on
it but
the research i'm doing at the moment is
is related to the question of who is
responsible and i would agree broadly i
assume with people here
uh that in an ideal world the government
would never have to intervene on this
stuff because it would just be easy to
be active and to eat well
but when that isn't happening or isn't
happening for enough people
what options do we have uh we can tell
businesses and sectors like schools to
make change as people or
uh as communities or whatever but if
they don't then that's where government
tends to feel pushed to make this happen
or it certainly justifies its action
to um to intervene i.e introduce
regulation legislation on these sorts of
things
and focusing on self-regulation i've
been recently analyzing government
obesity policies and have found that the
vast majority of policies
are um i will be promising this at last
point um
are proposed in a way that doesn't
readily lead to implementation
so even when they're not you know laws
or regulations of any sort but they're
indications of what should be done
they're proposed in such an
unclear and undetailed way or a way that
doesn't necessarily allow the sector to
implement that
that they are unlikely to then happen so
no wonder we end up in a position where
the government thinks you know what else
is there to do but to intervene and
that's what i find very
frustrating is i think that we probably
could have a lot more agreement i.e the
people that are slightly less
offended by intervention and those who
um are um where we
you know if policies were proposed if
actions were thought through in a way
that readily leads to implementation
then maybe we wouldn't need to
resort to government intervention on on
such a kind of
regulatory scale um so i will leave it
there and thank you
for having me thanks dolly over to chris
that's okay well so the question is is
this the tip of the iceberg obviously
not
i mean this is this is not the start of
the slippery slope we're
well down the slippery slope i mean the
government is on the brink
of banning the advertising of cheese
before 9 pm
if you make jam or pies or something
you'll never be able to advertise your
wares at all on the internet any time
day or night
now this clearly is not entry-level
nanny statism this is something that's
been
worked on and honed for decades uh
starting with smokers smokers have
traditionally brought born the brunt of
most of the nanny state policies
in this country over the last 15 20
years and as many people predicted it's
now
everybody else's turn whether they drink
alcohol or they gamble
or they want to eat um various types of
food
and it doesn't seem to matter who you
vote for it just carries on i mean boris
johnson
in as dolly's already suggested actually
has never done anything libertarian i
don't know where he gets his
reputation from his newspaper articles i
suppose he's never actually
done anything libertarian this this year
he's done the least libertarian thing
any prime minister
has ever done um so it doesn't seem to
matter who you vote for
and none of this stuff seems to be based
on any kind of liberal or conservative
principles or indeed socialist
principles it's based primarily on
opportunism
uh it's based on on you know
groundswell of um agitation from various
pressure groups which politicians for
some reason just seem
unable or unwilling to ignore but at the
root of it is
a basic coercive paternalism which in my
view is simply anti-social
it is rooted for all the excuses that
you hear about other costs of the nhs or
the
clearly fake statistics like the idea
that one in three 11 year olds is uh
overweight or obese
which is if you look into the how the
statistics are created it will blow your
mind
um for all the various excuses people
come up with at the root of it is the
desire
to stop people doing things that they
don't like that's what it comes down to
it goes really back to blair i think
blair kind of made it he kind of
normalized the idea
that if you don't like something you can
ban it and that's continued on now for
for over 20 years
um and in a liberal society that should
be considered an anti-social position
and unfortunately it's not and for that
reason the slippery slope has become a
runaway train
and i don't see any end inside
uh well uh dolly and chris make a decent
point there
the spectator looked at some of his old
columns when
this obesity strategy uh was uh
announced and brought forward again and
uh yes he does pen a lot of libertarian
ideas um
push back on obesity strategies smoking
bans even a compulsory child car
seats but i suppose putting it into
action is another story
um steve on that point though is there
any real evidence that this obesity
strategy is going to make a meaningful
difference can we point any
evidence in the world um i argue
it's hard to find it in the uk but even
in the world it suggests that these
kinds of advertising bans aren't going
to make the real difference
do you not have the concern that this is
just the first step and soon
uh more restrictions on people's
liberties will come into play
well look what i would say is that
in answer to what chris is saying and
what you're saying you know is that
it seems to be it's a bit it's a bit
like the um the anti-vaxxers or the
people in trafalgar square on the
weekend who are sort of saying you know
we don't we don't want this imposition
on our lives
you know what i don't want it either but
you know i didn't create a virus that's
killed nearly
nearly a a million people worldwide
and i would argue that in a publicly
funded health service
we not only have a duty but we have a
responsibility to act
you know we're not making this up to be
beastly to you
there are plenty of people in the food
and drink industry who don't think very
much
of us doing things to tell their right
to advertise domino pizzas
during the um during the x factor but
i'm sorry
they're not good for you and there's
plenty of evidence to suggest that
they're not good for you
in answer your question kate do i think
that this
obesity strategy the governor poured out
and i wrote some of it some of it we
consulted on two years ago it was then
got lost in the
in the craziness of the may government
and brexit in a general election
and has now been reheated um do i think
that on its own is going to make a
significant difference and move the dial
absolutely not no i don't that's why i
mentioned
early on in my remarks about the early
years agenda and about how we
actually teach young people about what
is healthy about what they put into
their bodies
and what is healthy about the exercise
they do to take the calories out
we don't want uh people trudging around
in unhappiness but we do want people to
lead healthy lifestyles and when you
have a publicly funded health service i
think you have a responsibility to make
sure that that happens
because because ultimately i mean we
heard mention of
the war on smoking i mean honestly
given how many people in this world
smoking has killed are we seriously
suggesting that it wasn't a right public
health measure
to try and discourage educate and
steer people away from smoking i'm sorry
it's just utter
nonsense of a sort of grumpy
center-right view of the world
which is that we can just step back and
let everybody be that's what led to the
herd mentality view
around covid which thank goodness we
didn't listen to
joanna on this point about the national
health service
if you do have a health body that is
publicly funded as well as publicly run
at some point there's going to have to
be a crackdown on the way that people
live their lives
because if everybody decides to make
decisions that could put them in a
detrimental health position
we're not going to be able uh to take
care of them let alone healthier people
who are coming in for other ailments
i think i think what steve's saying
there and um his continual retorts to
the fact that we've got a publicly
funded health service
so we all better behave what we do joe i
think
but sorry if i can just finish my point
steve
um i think it's really interesting
because up until six months ago
the nhs was always there to look after
us
if we got sick the nhs protected
the population something's really
changed over the past six months
now we are supposed to protect the nhs
we are supposed to change how we lead
our lives
and how we um conduct ourselves
in order to protect the nhs now that's
completely utterly bizarre
and we are not going to hospital when
we're suffering from heart pains
not going to the doctors when we detect
a lump not taking our children to
accident and emergency
because we're so worried about putting a
strain
on this publicly funded nhs that's
supposed to be about protecting
us i'm not sure if it was a freudian
slip steve but i noticed you were
talking at the end there about
this was how we got to people talking
about herd mentality
in relation to coronavirus now my
understanding is that nobody ever talked
about herd mentality
people talked about herd immunity which
is a reasonable scientific proposition
in relation to coronavirus
but i think herd mentality is very
interesting for how
lots of mps seem to see the population
nowadays
as a herd that needs managing and
berating
and being told what to do for the re for
the purposes of the economy and to
protect the nhs
frankly i find it quite insulting i'm
going to move on to
dolly and get back specifically to the
topic of obesity although
points taken johanna and dolly
when we're talking about obesity stats
we
very often look at people as a drain on
the healthcare resources that we have
but of course these are individuals
and the fast fast majority of adults
are in a position to make their own
choices i think it's hard to argue in
the uk that people are undereducated on
this issue
so at what point do you say that people
have actually decided to make a choice
and it might not be the one that you
would make
but people should be allowed to consume
what they want as long as they're not
harming anybody else
yeah so i mean it is the kind of crux on
this
issue um it's it's about what it means
to make a choice and
again this is where it's fascinating in
terms of short medium long term
outcomes you know we all make choices um
depending on on our surroundings and
they may not necessarily be compatible
with say longer term
outcomes so we can say that we would
love to you know get a sex pack
um and then lo and behold i'm not doing
the exercise
that is a very real reality
um but my but my point is more just um
it always comes across as a very kind of
extreme
view um when we're talking about things
uh
in relation to obesity policy and that's
why i try and really emphasize my point
earlier about just making it easier it's
really not sort of pointing fingers and
making people feel guilty and
you know and this links into a lot of
the the problem with the framing side of
things as it's linked very much to
aesthetic
and and fat shaming which i know that a
lot of the kind of charities
focus much more on um and really i kind
of want to move away from that
and away from the weight um obsession
and ideally
we would just be talking about how easy
it is for anyone regardless of your
circumstance who you are what
opportunities you have
forget education you know educate we
know what we need to be doing it doesn't
necessarily
you know make it happen for us um if
it's not easy in our in our context and
i think that's where
my colleagues um quote that i read out
earlier about irrespective of how much
education encouragement and motivation
we give people
to make these choices if it's um not
conducive in your in your context and
it's bloody difficult and um
and i think everyone can can um uh
you know kind of think of experiences in
their own life where it's not always
you you don't always sort of are able to
to kind of make happen what you would
like to happen
because of various things it's not to
say that we're stupid or anything i'm
talking literally from my own experience
it's not always easy
and that train journey i give as an
example because as much as i would like
to have eaten something
healthier and made that choice because
it wasn't there a proper choice you know
choice that we can all agree on
um i ended up eating nothing because i
didn't really want to go down the crisp
and
and chocolate route so i'm i'm asking
for proper choice
and one where you know treats aren't
so much more available or even the only
option
so real choice and i and i hope that
would be something that we would all
aspire towards absolutely chris if we
go back to before the covert crisis and
these new restrictions on our liberties
britain is a pretty free country um
i mean very very free is banning
advertisements around certain kinds of
junk food
really the end of the world is that the
hill to die on when it comes to
an obesity strategy or the nanny state
more broadly is it
is it really fair to say that
restrictions on ads certainly before 9
pm not even banning them all together
um is is is is truly a slippery slope is
that really the end of liberty
of course not it's all incremental they
wouldn't get away with it if they said
what they wanted to do up front they
have to do it salami slice
uh style um this is exactly about that
in the 1960s well we're only banning
tv advertising before nine o'clock i was
so bad about that now you look at the
way
smokers are basically second-class
citizens because we've seen 50 years of
incremental
movement on this i expect exactly the
same thing to happen to people who want
to
enjoy fatty or sugary foods in the
future then why not the logic dictates
that that's where you go eventually you
will see
these food products in plain packaging
because why wouldn't you the
the logic um inevitably i think drives
you to that just to go back to
this cost to the nhs thing if i may very
quickly
um you again you heard this excuse with
smokers
the reality is it's the aging society
which is putting huge burdens on
the nhs fat people pay taxes for one
thing
and for another thing they would only
die something else if they were not fat
okay you can't just use the half truth
that there are costs associated with
obesity or smoking without looking at
what the cost would have been
had they never smoked or become obese
this is an excuse it's what i was saying
before people will come up with all
sorts of excuses
to justify what is basically prejudice
and paternalism
um sorry steve very quickly this is a
short panel but i'm going to let you
come back um i just want to uh we're
going to wrap up
uh so i want to go around and have each
of you make a closing remark the
question i would put to you
uh is what would you like to see instead
well perhaps you want to see exactly the
status quo but ideally from your
perspective
what should the government be doing or
not doing in order to tackle
obesity and you can answer that how you
wish you each have 30 seconds steve go
ahead
look the government can and it should
play a role
i would suggest in shaping an
environment that supports
everyone to be healthy you know it's
much harder to be for families to be
healthy when unhealthy food is cheaper
than healthy food the point of the dolly
made and takeaways are on every corner
on the run up to schools and oversized
portions of the norm every time we
switch on the tv
or go online we'll be bombarded by
advertisements for unhealthy food types
and burgers and chips
you know i don't think it's in any state
to want the population to be protected
from
an increased risk of developing type 2
diabetes heart disease cancer
and now complications from from kobit
19. i think that's the action as a
responsible government we've seen the
impact of government legislation on
with things like the soft drinks levy
the sugar tax which led to a dramatic
reduction of your content in soft drinks
and i'm very proud
that i was part of the government that
brought that in you know proposed
action that we're taking in the rest of
the plan on its own as i've said even
the 9 pm water shed and junk food
adverts and
the bog offs of the supermarket counters
none of that on its own
is going to is going to turn around this
super tanker but we have a
responsibility
to tackle ill health in a popular in a
population in a publicly funded health
service
and and i don't think a conservative
government or any government
should should make an apology for that
and i would end by saying this
when you say well it doesn't matter who
you vote for
it's always the same outcome well then
maybe that spans different parties and
different governments and maybe that
suggests
there's a consensus here and you know
what if you don't like what we're doing
vote us out joanna
i think the government and previous
governments and future governments need
to
stop imposing restrictions on us stop
telling us how to live our lives
whether that's through direct
impositions and rules
and bans or whether it's through nudge
things like calorie counts or menus
and all the different ways in which
government tries to manipulate us and
get us to behave in particular ways
i think just stop let people learn how
to take responsibility for their own
lives
and make their own decisions um it seems
to me
when i've looked at health statistics
that one of the
biggest correlations with ill health and
particularly ill health that comes about
from lifestyle factors
is poverty and unfortunately if you
drop bog off deals in the absence
of bringing about major economic
investment and
improving people's employment
opportunities and raising people's
income levels you're actually going
further in impoverishing
the nation you make the single mum who
lives on a council estate who has very
little money
you give her fewer choices when you
remove the bog off deals
and you don't suddenly make her think oh
great i'll buy
three pounds of carrots you just make
her be able to afford less
you make people poorer and it's that
poverty
that has far worse outcomes for people's
health in the long run
dolly thanks so much um
yeah i think we agree on on meaningful
choice
um and basically striving towards that
and
and for me i will repeat one more time
on wanting it just to be easier
regardless of
circumstance and other things going on
in our lives to live a healthy life
without having to think about it too
much and without having to take away
any meaningful choice but my but my
really big push when it comes to
actually the specific question
in a policy context is i would love if
government obesity policy was proposed
in a way that was conducive to
implementation or at least um scrutiny
that is so rare if you look at this
strategy the fascinating thing is
they've got
a number of policies that are proposed
and there is a bit more detail and then
right at the bottom it says it
recognizes that that won't be sufficient
and then just bullet point lists
other actions and they're literally one
line each
is that a policy you know how do we even
follow up if that's
going to happen who's responsible who's
accountable how much is it going to cost
all you know what the evidence behind it
is absolutely proposed with nothing
like that just one sentence and that for
me is just poor
policy um so i would love it if uh
obesity policy in fact all government
policy was proposed in a
in a much more conducive way to
implementation or at least scrutiny
and chris yeah i'm sorry dolly wasn't
able to get a salad on a train but i
don't think it's really
um a good example of the salad chris
didn't eat anything and at all in the
end so maybe that was a good obesity
strategy from the trade um you know
that's not typical of the way people buy
food if you go into the supermarket the
first thing you see is loads of fruit
and veg it's extremely cheap the healthy
choice actually is usually cheap
cheaper and you generally as convenient
as a so-called unhealthy choice
it's always cheaper to drink water than
fizzy drinks it's always cheaper to not
smoke than smoke it's always cheaper to
drink
soft drinks rather than alcoholic drinks
when public health people say they want
to make the healthier choices
easier in practice when you look at the
policies it's about making the so-called
unhealthy choices more inconvenient
more expensive which has the effect on
people on low incomes in particular john
has
already mentioned it's all destructive
if it was more constructive they
genuinely were
making the healthy choices easier then i
would be much more supportive but
they're not
well that was a fantastic panel uh i
think i'm not sure we came to
consensus but i think we did our very
best
dolly steve joanna and chris thank you
for talking through
those ideas with us on spectator tv
today um
for those of you who are planning on
tuning in to the next panel
uh you have about 10 minutes to get a
drink of water or a glass of wine as
chris is doing and come back to see
fraser nelson interview
uh kenny betanock call one of the
equalities ministers
and we also are doing a whole host of
panels tomorrow
and wednesday as well but for now a big
thanks to our panel sorry we can't thank
you in the usual way i'm sure people are
applauding at home
and a big thanks to the institute for
economic affairs for arranging it
have a great day
you